Hello everybody my name is Markiplier, and welcome to 'Whack the Creeps.'
The latest edition in the long line of games of barely justifiable homicide.
And you guys know the drill: it's gonna be bloody and horrible and violent so if you're not...
keen on that stuff...
don't watch it cause there's about to be a lot of blood.
Oh...
I- I like the way you laugh without moving your lips
it really is a very endearing to you.
And I'm so glad that obviously we bond together because we enjoy wanting murders, so- oh.
Hi.
Okay... Oh geez.
Yeah, yeah, you better not.
You better back off.
Wait my hair?
Why was my hair an option?
Uh huh. That wasn't exactly my hair.
Oh geez, of course.
*laugh*
Oh.
Whoa, we already punished him!
Why is this necessary?!
You're going a step too far!
Oh... nevermind then. Why not ! You know, why not.
Wait you murdered the other guy, you're just gonna leave that guy with a spike?!
Oh...
Thank you bartender who is oddly okay with watching this lady murder these two people in horrible fashion.
You gotta clean the blood up off the floor.
Everything is okay in his book!
He's incredibly high...
Okay!
My goodness gracious...
(imitates character's laugh) Oh yeah, taser!
Oh boy.
Okay...
Yeah, don't worry about it.
Uh-oh. Yeah, don't- *surprised noise*
*Markimoo.exe is not responding*
Why is everything about the balls?!?!
I mean, I get it: I'm a strong, independent woman who don't n- AGAIN!?
WHY?!
It's a little too much, don't you think?
Oh, my g- OH! This is gonna be a loop, over and over again! Oh, I -
Oh, nope! Ah, never mind.
Alright, well, uh...lipstick.
Okay!
You know, you're incredibly creative here if you're able to murder these people with such normal, everyday objects.
Oh, boy...
Uhh-huhh!
Uh-huh-huhhh!
HohoHOHohoho!
*confused moaning/groaning*
WHOA!
Why?!
Why was that a gun?!
Who carries explosive lipstick?!
What if it goes off while you're applying it?!
It'd blow your brains out!
That's horrible!
It's a bad idea all around! Ah, geez...
Okay...
"Completed secret agent." I don't know what that means! What do you mean 'secret agent?'
Is that because of the lipstick? I don't understand.
Darts...
"Object requires a second to work."
What do you mean? Dartboard, of course.
Yeah?
It'd only makes sense.
Uh huh.
Okay.
(imitates girl's blabbering)
This is going to be fun! Come join me! It's going to be totally cool!
Yeah...
Woah-oh-oh... *laughs*
Why I oughta!
You just, darted me in the back!
But boy, am I angry!
Ohh...
Okay.
Well...
That's a quite a powerful throw you got there if you made it go all the way through his head,
I'm very impressed.
And also I'm disgusted,
but mostly impressed.
"Bull's Eye!"
I don't care about these achievements! They're all horrible!
Hi. Oh. Hi.
AGAIN!? Oh I thought that was in the balls again. I was gonna be very- WHOA!
Nice moves, lady!
(imitating guy) "Oh no!"
H-he's begging for mercy! Oh geez...
Oh...
Well I guess that didn't kill him- oh no...
*quiet, slightly concerned laughter*
Just blood-
*sounds of guy very likely getting his head beaten into the toilet, water splashing, and drowning*
*regret laughter* OH GOD I WAS RIGHT! Augh I called it!
OH. The other guy is arguably still alive and totally fine and he's gonna wake up to find the puddle of blood
that was once his friend...
*chuckling* Oh my god. Is there more?
Could there possibly be more?
Are you gonna finish him off too?
Ohh that's the end then. I'll move on.
Oh boy.
Heugh. Beer? You boys want some beer?
Huuuh?
I don't know what kind of pose that was.
He didn't even seem marginally upset about that.
Oh thanks for the assist on the murder!
*Guy near counter: "H-hey hey hey no nO NO!
*sounds of guy being forced beer down the throat while making unpleasant choking noises*
*Guy groaning in pain and burping*
OH.
*glass clinking*
*slurp* *ahh*
Okay...
Once again, other guy totally fine and alive and this guy just seems to be the magnet for murder.
Oh man- euh, "Beer Boarding." Oh that's a pleasant achivement. I'm so happy that I got that.
(half-imitating guy) "Whoo whoo whoo..."
Ha. "Whoo whoo" indeed.
"Whoo WHOO whoo whoo-" Ohhhhhhh...
WHOA-HO-HO-HO-HO-HO...
*regret laughing* OhhohO WHY IS EVERYTHING FIIIIINE?
WHY IS EVERYTHING IS FIIIIINE...?
*very questioning worried laugh? *
One of these days I wanna go into this- oh a hat.
Perfectly ordinary and non-deadly hat. It's gonna be fine. Everyone's- oh. Uh-
*very surprised noises*
"WHAT THE-?!" YEAH I'D BE AS SURPRISED AS YOU ARE BRUH! OH...
*girl giggling evilly*
(imitates evil giggling that trails off)
Are you- wHY BARTENDER?! WHY DO YOU LET THAT IN YOUR PLACE OF ESTABLISHMENT!?
Bar...
It's just-
I'm just- my- my engineering brain is trying to find the logic out of it!
I mean I know they're creeps, but why were prepared for war when you went into this bar?
My goodness.
(imitates girl?)
Oh...
Oh- OHHHHHHHH...
WHOA...
Oh-OHHH IT WAS DONE.
He was already done.
Euh...
OH GOD.
*girl giggling evilly*
Ohhhoho better protect yourself from the shower of blood, my goodness.
This is unecessary.
It's unholy!
Jukebox. What do we got?
I'm now becoming numb to the pain.
It's all fine. I get it.
I accept and understand this as reality as it needs to be.
Humana, hamana.
Hamana, hamana, hamana-
They were just trying to enjoy mu-
*funky pop music*
*"Dance Of The Sugar Plum Fairy"*
*hip-hop music*
Oh hi.
Hello.
Who're you?
*sounds of security grunting and breaking jukebox*
Ah...
Thank you.
Again, another employee that I've never seen before that didn't care I was murdering them, a million times in
a million other ways?
*glass click* *slurp*
Why do these people come to this bar in the first place?
"Pool ball."
Pool ball.
Pool ball?
You guys wanna play some pool? You boys wanna play?
Yeah?
Totally innocent. Don't think anything of it. It's totally fine.
Uh-huh. Yeah. Everything's gonna be fine!
*sound of poolball straight to the forehead*
Oh.
(mocking angry guy) "H-Hey! That was my friend you just murdered! OW! Oh that hurt a lot!"
Uh oh.
Wh- how is this g-?
Okay?
Well- I don't think-?
*stuttering*
Uh, the things I know about human anatomy...
I'm pretty sure that's not how that would've worked and I don't know why he kept his head on the table for it to be
able to ram down his throat...
You weren't even looking at the drink when you took a drink of it!
That didn't make any sense!
Alright, "pool cue" plus...
"pool ball?" No.
Ah- oh! Ah-ha, there was another pool cue! Ah yes! This will be the murder that I've alway desired!
Which is none
(attempt at a high pitched girl voice) "Hey do you wanna play pool? It's gonna fuuuun!"
(normal voice) OH. It was a deception.
(*laughing* It was a deception the whole time.
(to Chica) Chica, help save me from this horrible murder. This bloody experience.
(to game) Yeah you just stand there, don-don't worry about it- Oh , oh you begging for his life?
Well when does that ever stop me before? *laughing*
Oh...
Well.
I don't think he's dead.
Yet...
(weakly) Hahahaha... ha...
"Call staff."
*girl whistles*
Uh-huh.
*garbled intercom sound*
Oh hey! Welcome back, buddy!
Yeah bouncer, these creeps have been giving me trouble. You should just throw them out all calmly-
*laughing*
*still laughing*
*still slightly laughing*
Yeah that's- that's what we were hoping for.
Oh he's alive- OH!
(high pitched) OH.
*quiet laughter*
O-kay
Alright then.
Let's go up on the roof.
Hey boys, wanna join me on th- okay, well.
Am I gonna punch... him to the- welp, that's... again, there's a lotta... there's a lot of impacts to testicular
region. Oh. Bye friend! We'll see you in a bit.
"Two minutes late..." Oh boy.
Wh- oh. Oh. Oh.
What, I couldn't have thrown him off? Oh-
*car screeching*
*guy with drink chuckling at the creep's demise*
WH- I THOUGHT THAT'S YOUR GIRLFRIEND UP THERE. I THOUGHT YOU WENT TO THE BATHROOM?!
OR SOMETHIN'?
WHAT DO- WHAT DO YOU GOT YOUR FOOT ON?!
THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE!
Okay, whatever.
Oh he went to go have a "snook" [smoke].
Alright pencil. Let's see...
Oh hey! Yeah, would you like my number? All innocuous and innocent?
I'm sure this is gonna go lovely for you.
Uh.
Oh no... Oh. I get it.
I-I get it. I get the refere- oh hey how's it goin'? You don't get a magic trick. You just get death apparently.
*laughing* Oh god, oh god.
Oh it's enough!
*laughing* He's already dead.
*still laughing*
Ah shoes. "High heel." Please don't stomp on this balls.
Oh no.
Oh nO.
OH NO- OHHH.
OH NOT ENTIRELY WHAT I WAS EXPECTING.
I don't know if it's any better.
(extremely high pitched) NO. OH GOD.
*high pitched stuttering/laughing* This is exactly what I didn't want.
*distressed Mark sounds*
*glass clinking*
Why did you do that...?
Alright then...
Mmmmmmmmmmmm...
Playing a quality game...
"Family-friendly fun for the whole family."
Mmmmm...
Have I done "wine?" I don't think I've done "wine" yet.
Haha! Oh that's what you get.
And this what you get. He get- oh no.
He got a slight purse to the face. You get... instant death- *disturbed laughter*
*still laughing* Oh no...
*still laughing* Oh god...
Euh... it's too much for my fragile brain.
Oh, my innocent eyes.
What are they doing being subjected to this "hor-ror."
(sighing) Oh boy.
Is there anything else in my purse? Oh. "Pepper spray." I didn't even see that before. Okay.
"Pepper spray?" Alright. (sigh)
A non-lethal solution, hopefully.
Usually.
(imitating guys' anguished screaming)
*sounds of guys screaming pain as pepper spray is being unleashed towards them*
What-? How did she kill him?! How did he make him pass out- oh god.
Again... arguably a non-lethal solution, but you didn't need to smack him upside the head with a bar stool.
And I don't know how that guy passed out.
*rewinding sound mixed with the rewind sounds of screams*
Whoa-ho-ho-ho.
"You've unlocked the final kill: The Last Call."
Uh...
How do I do that "Last Call" thing?
Where's the "Last Call," huh?
Oh, here we go, "Patrick." Aah!
Oooh. I see. Not the umbrella.
Oh not that, probably not that, no. Oh?! Yeah!
"Last-" oh, they're gonna call in! "This kill will require action events so be ready."
I'M NOT READY.
I-I have to cover ands shield my eyes from the horror, oh boy.
*laughing* Oh no...
Hello.
Oh we're all gonna come together for this one.
Yeah, buddy!
Murder, right?!
Yeah, friend!
Killing people who barely deserve it! Probably.
*high pitched scream*
Oh god!
Well that didn't- that was less than lethal.
I'm okay with this.
*not as high pitched scream*
Ha-boink!
Welp.
That sure taught 'em a- oh. *laughing*
You sqooshed his top half of his head. *laughing*
*laughing*
Oh boy...
AHHHHHHHHHH... his pelvis!
OHHHHH.
Something's wrong- OH. He's- OH COME ON HIS BRAIN'S ALREADY BEEN "DABLAGED" [DAMAGED] ENOUGH!
Ohhhh good lordy- oh...
*slightly distrubed laughing* Oh my god.
WHY'RE YOU MOONWALKING?1
Oh. I thou- oh shit.
AH FUCK. I WAS TOO DISTRACTED BY THE FACT THAT HE MOONWALKED.
Once more into the breach- *disturbed Mark sounds*
*continous disturbed/disgruntled Mark sounds*
Ha-BOINK!
Oh okay.
That's a nice decoration to keep in the bar.
BYE EVERYBODY! BYE FRIENDS!
Oh it was good to see you again! Enjoy experiences together and share memories for as long
as we shall live.
*tone of regret* Yaaay I did it.
*regret sounds*
Heeeuuuuuuugh.
"Coming soon: Whack The Serial Killer."
OKAY,
THAT SEEMS LIKE SOMEONE WHO MIGHT MAYBE DESERVE THIS PUNISHMENT
I GUESS?!?!
For the first time in the series of this game?!
Alright...
The funny thing is like,
one- oh man, ah- there's- nevermind.
I have no words of wisdom to say at the end of this episode. All I'll say is thank you everybody so much for
watching. If you wanna see the rest of the series of this game, *music* you can find it in the link in the description with a
playlist. It's got them all in there. A bunch of bloody,  gory, intense action for you all to enjoy.
So thank you again everybody!
And as always, I will see you... in the next video!
BUH-BYE!
Thanks grandma,
have a good day grandma.
Don't worry i'll clean up this mess, grandma
NOT HIS CROTCH!!!
NOT HIS BUTT?!!
AAAAAH!!
*markiplier sfx* Well that's just mean.